[Musique]
au coeur du grand nord américain et met
le plus célèbre des chiens-loups nous
appellerons croc blanc et tu seras le
plus grand des chiens de traîneau
[Musique]
le temps est venu pour toi de grandir il
découvrira l'affection et la tendresse
des heures il apprendra des dangers et
la grandeur du monde sauvage
il paraît que c'est la terreur du yukon
je croyais que c'était moi la terreur
d'une coque feuilleter un ange vous êtes
deux ans
[Musique]
et il suscitera la convoitise de
certains hommes et indiens pour un chien
comme lui je suis prêt à payer une
fortune il me pauvre regretter d'avoir
croisé la route de biot dit smith
ce chien m'appartient
[Musique]
cette année re découvrez l'incroyable
destinée de croc blanc et vivait avec
lui un grand moment de complicité
à toi de leur montrer qui tu es
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]